翻訳: Yumi Urushihara
校正: Shoko Takaki
こんにちは 皆様
ほとんどの皆様は
SF映画をご覧になっていると思います
『スター・トレック』や
『スター・ウォーズ』のような
映画をご覧になっていると思います
でも 今お見せしているのは
SFの映画でもありません
コンピューターグラフィックスでも
ありません
これは本物のビデオで
私と私の乗員仲間がスペースシャトル
「ディスカバリー」に
乗船している時に撮った映像です
これは 2010年のことで
ISS国際宇宙ステーションから
切り離された時から 撮っている映像です
で ISSは 未だに地球の周りを
マッハ25―音速25で
周回をしています
これは秒速８kmの速度です
で 今お見せしているのも
実際の速度であり
早送りをしていません
今日は 皆様と３つのことを
ご共有したいと思っております
まずは 「地球の美しさ」です
このビデオで ご覧頂けます通り
素晴らしい自然を見ることができます
山、川、白い雲、そして青い海
そして時には
北極、南極では 素晴らしい
オーロラ等も見ることができます
本当に息を呑むばかりです
でも同時に
驚くべきことなんですけれども
地球を取り巻く大気層が
あまりにも薄いということです
そして 私たちは皆
この薄い 脆弱な層
大気層によって
守られているということを
知ると驚きます
そして太陽が昇り そして落ちるまで
これは90分に１回
起こるんですけれども
大気層の薄い層が
虹のように光ります
とても美しいです
そして
バックミンスター・フラー氏は
かつて地球のことを
「宇宙船地球号」と述べました
私自身は 本当に
地球は宇宙船だと感じました
もちろん大きいのですけれども
無限でもない
土地も資源も有限である
という意味で
宇宙船と感じました
ということで
宇宙船地球号をより良い方法で
使っていかなければなりません
というのも 世界人口も また
エネルギー消費量も
どんどん増えているからです
ですので 宇宙船地球号を
自分たちの持てる資源を
対立をするのではなく
積極的に使えるように
うまく使いこなして
いかなければなりません
２つ目に共有したいアイデアは
「人間の力の話」です
日中 素晴らしい自然が
目の前に展開します
でも 夜には都市の照明が
輝いて美しいのです
これは人間の文明の
象徴 [である] かのようです
また ISSを見て
びっくりしたことがあるのです
ISSに対して 近づいていって
そして ビデオで見ているように
ISSから離れている時に
驚いたんですけれども
幅は100メートル
長さ75メートルのISSは
ちょうど サッカー場と同じぐらい
巨大なものなのですけれども
これは国際的な協力[無くしては]
できないことです
ということで
人間の国境を越えた協力の賜物です
ISSプロジェクトは
1980年代に西洋諸国が始めた
プロジェクトです
ヨーロッパ、アメリカ
カナダ、日本が主要国です
そして 冷戦が終わった後―
これは1990年初頭ですけれども―
冷戦が終わってからは
ロシアが参加を始めました
ということで
事態はどんどん変わっていきます
様々な多くの国々が
協力をきっとするんだと思います
将来の有人宇宙探査船に関してです
例えば 月や
それより遠い所に
宇宙船の探査を送ることに関してです
というのは こういった 火星に
探査船を送るようなプロジェクトというのは
一国ではやりきれません
ということで
より大規模な国際協力が必要です
そのためにも グローバル経済
グローバル政治は
より安定していなければなりません
私たちは ボーダーレスな
国境を越えた協力が必要です
で 国境がない という所で
私たちは多分
この宇宙探査船の中でも
協力を より―
国境を超えてしていくと
もっと より良いことが
起きていくと思います
こういう
より良いシナジー効果が
益々 地上と そして宇宙の間で
進むことを願っています
最近 私は感銘を受けたことがあります
冥王星の写真を見たからです
「ニュー・ホライズンズ」
探査機が撮った映像ですけれども
この達成に対して
おめでとうと申し上げたいと思います
世界中の人々が
このスペースミッションに対して
貢献をして下さり
そしてサポートしてきて下さったことに
対しても 感謝を申し上げます
最後に もう１点
共有したい点があります
「母なる宇宙
マザースペース」です
初めて宇宙に到達をして
そして無重力を経験した時
これはちょうど
ディスカバリーが打ち上げられて
8分30秒後のことだったんですけれども
本当にびっくりしました
無重力に入ると
宙返りは何回もできるのです
そして天井からは
自由にぶら下がれます
そしてまた 天井に立つことも
問題なくできます
絶対的な上、下というのは
無いのです
皆さんの体勢に応じて
上と下が決まってきます
ということで
「あなたの場合の上の方を向いて」
あるいは
「あなたの場合の下を向いて」という風に
人によって体勢が違うので―
［そう］言わなければ
なりませんでした
本当に目から鱗が
落ちるような経験でした
他の人の立場に立たない限り
自分たちはコミュニケーションが
できなかったのです
そして 感銘を受けたのは
なぜか 初めて宇宙に着いた時に
「馴染みのある所だ」と感じたことです
初めてなのに
身近な場所と感じたのです
私たちは皆
星の欠片からできています
太陽、地球、そしてどの生物
私たちも含めて
皆 星の欠片から 構成されています
つまり 宇宙は私たちにとって
遠い存在ではありません
多分 私たちのふるさとなのです
だからこそ 多分
身近に宇宙を感じたんだと思います
だから私は 宇宙を「マザースペース」と
呼びたいと感じています
マザースペースは 私たちのために
私たちの 幸せと平和を
祈ってくれているはずです
丁度 親が子の幸せを
祈るかのようにです
あるいは 教師が
子供の幸せを願うようにです
そして 母なる宇宙
マザースペースは
私たちが成長して更に
成熟している姿を見たいはずです
そして マザースペースは
私たちが互いに気を遣い合って
そして 前向きに手を携えて
地上でも頑張るところを
見ていたいと思うはずです
宇宙は本当に美しく
でも 地上にまた戻ってきた時
風を感じました
そして 景観を見ました
そして 小さな花々、草花の
匂いを嗅いだ時に
本当に嬉しく 幸福感がありました
ということで 本当の幸福感は
私たちの周囲にあるんだと思います
遠い所にある訳ではありません
そういったことを考えると
より 国々は国境を越えて コネクトしていく
繋がっていくと思います
そして 地上と宇宙も
繋がっていくに違いありません
そして マザースペースは
私たちがもっと協力をすることを
待っていると思っています
協力をして 私たちがもっと
更に［頻繁に］宇宙に行ける
そして 彼女に会いに行くことを
望んでいるんだと思います
ですので 私は更に
多くの人々が宇宙に行けるように
尽力をしたいと思います
そしてそれは 国境の無い世界に
より貢献をしていくと思います
母なる宇宙 マザースペースは
私たちを待っていて下さると思います
ご清聴ありがとうございます
そして皆さん TEDの主催者の皆様
ご尽力をありがとうございます